c'est une vie des otages qui est un
objet sexuel pour tout un tas d'hommes
elle était vierge marie elle était pour
elle le jour de sa mort c'est le jour où
elle a été la perte de sa virginité par
un viol
marie c'est une femme très menue elle a
la caractéristique d'abord les cheveux
auburn enfin blond blond vénitien
on voit tout de suite c'est une femme
qui a un fort caractère dire c'est ce
que racontait tous ses voisins
c'est très récent elles n'étaient pas
comme les autres c'était une chrétienne
elle était cultivée parti faire ses
études à bagdad elle voulait étudier
l'anglais
elle voulait devenir professeur elle
voulait tomber amoureuse et c'est quand
même la vie aussi d'une jeune femme
comme comme une autre comme comme il y
en a tant
les chrétiens ont des informations
contradictoires et notamment les kurdes
et puis même les gens de l'état
islamique leur dise qu'ils ne risquent
rien on entend quand même bon quelques
bombes qui tombent etc ils savent pas
très bien ce qu'il faut faire à ce
moment-là l'évêque donne une messe dans
l'église de qaraqosh a l'air d'y rester
il n'y a pas de problème voilà on a reçu
des assurances de la part des généraux
curdy nous défendrons s'il se passe
quelque chose mais de toute façon vous
ne risquez rien et il faut résister il
faut qu'on soit là externe
et puis il ya un moment où il ya
d'autres bombes qui tombent
une famille est touchée et là tout d'un
coup là on comprend qu'il faut partir
les kurdes sont pas du tout là pour les
défendre ils ont tout abandonné
lévesque leur dis partez fier et donc là
il ya une espèce de grandes
transhumances quoi où tout le monde
entassent toutes ces affaires à ce
moment là marie enfin la soeur de marie
plus exactement dit non non je vais pas
partir donc marie veut pas la laisser
puis elles sont réconfortés d'être
ensemble et elles vivent pendant
quelques jours dans d'ankara coach et
puis tout d'un coup ça y est c'est trop
tard elles peuvent plus partir au moment
où elle aimerait elle voit que la ville
a été investie que qui a les patrouilles
partout que la ville est occupée en fait
et puis un jour on les rassemble et dans
une cour et puis on organise on organise
leur enlèvement
et ce qui est notable c'est qu'en fait
les trois soeurs ont été ont été
enlevées mais les deux autres ont été
relâchées très vite
c'est une vie des otages qui est qu' un
objet sexuel pour tout un tas d'hommes
elle était vierge marie elle était pour
elle le jour de sa mort c'est le jour où
elle a été là perdu sa virginité par un
viol
on a quand même l'impression parce
qu'elles racontaient qu'ils avaient tous
considération pour sa force de caractère
elle est tombée du premier étage elle a
été brûlée elle a été mais elle leur
rappeler à chaque fois leur loi en temps
vous pouvez pas aller trop loin il y
avait un manuel d esclavage qui faisait
qu' il y avait quand même une manière de
torture est une manière de se comporter
avec son esclave marielle elle a
toujours protesté elle a toujours crié
elle s'est toujours débattue elle a
toujours demandé à voir le juge de paix
islamique est la revendiquer ses droits
et jusqu'au bout tout le temps que tous
étaient c'est vraiment une femme
exceptionnelle l'état islamique venait
juste de partir et c'était incroyable
c'est parce que on voyait tous les
signes de cette armée en déroute
il avait coupé leur barbe alors il y
avait des barbes qui volaient dans l'air
il y avait eu des exactions de convoyer
on voyait des crânes enfin c'était et
puis il avait abandonné aussi leurs
munitions et il avait on pouvait aller
dans les tunnels qu'ils avaient creusé
il y avait quelques très rares chrétiens
parce qu'ils étaient très âgés souvent
qui étaient restés dans la ville
et c'est comme ça que j'ai entendu
parler pour la première fois de mari et
qu'elle avait subi et là je me suis
rendu compte que c'était ça a été la
victime qui avait subi le plus d'horreur
en fait
[Musique]
évidemment d'abord il fallait lui
laisser le temps de se remettre un peu
ne serait ce que physiquement de tout ce
qu'elle avait subi elle a suivi
après beaucoup d'opérations et puis
surtout le héros dont on parle dans
notre livre qu'il a qui l'a sauvée
voulait d'abord quelle qu'elle soit
entendue par la cour pénale
internationale
on a eu beaucoup de rendez vous manqués
on est on a fait plusieurs fois le
voyage en irak et puis ça se passait
jamais et puis un jour finalement on a
pu la rencontrer elle était d'une
précision incroyable ce qui fait que
parfois
enfin pour nous c'était absolument
insupportable à entendre m elle c'était
un peu comme si elle était détaché de ce
qu'elle avait vécu et donc elles
comptent parfois ça l'amusait le
comprenait pas les mêmes non mais je
veux continuer mais c'était elle elle
pouvait continuer mais non on n'arrivait
plus à l'écouté
en ce qui est très beau je vous dis
c'est presque sa joie de vivre c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui a une espérance qui
veut vivre qui a gardé la foi ça c'est
incroyable parce que quand on l'emmène
sur tous ces lieux en jordanie là où le
christ aurait été baptisé elle était
très émue elle et elle a continué à dire
ces prières dans son coeur il ya juste
un moment où elle nous a demandé mais où
était dieu quand j'étais à mossoul
pour moi c'est l'homme la chose la plus
incroyable que j'ai entendu que j'étais
choisi le moins incroyable parce que
parce que c'est beau aussi la manière
dont elle a voulu s'en sortir
il y avait deux lacunes dans mes
reportages qui était pourtant assez
siph c'était les femmes parce que
souvent la guerre écrase tout et qu'on
n'a pas le temps de se pencher
spécifiquement sur les femmes et puis
parce qu'en plus c'est plus dur de les
approcher et puis évidemment les
chrétiens on voit qu'il ya que c'est une
religion qui est qui est en voie de
disparition dans cet endroit du monde
sous la dictature de saddam il avait
quand même droit de cité et il était un
peu la colonne cérébrale de l'irak parce
que 40 % des médecins est par exemple
était chrétien 30 % des ingénieurs voilà
donc on assiste est vraiment à une
éradication avec la montée de
l'intégrisme l'implantation d'abord d'al
qaïda qui s'est transformée en état
islamique
je pense qu'on n'en fait pas personne
n'en fait assez enfin je veux dire c'est
dur d'assister à ça c'est un peu comme
l'histoire qui se répète quoi sûr on
voit pas qu'il ya quand même
l'éradication d'une culture
si on veut pas parler de religion disons
d'une culture pour cette partie du monde
bon c'est le berceau et